PLAYOFFS SO I DON'T CARE WHAT
THEY SAY.
I AM PLAYING.
COME TO FIND OUT, EIGHT WEEKS
LATER, IT SHOWED THAT I HAD A
NONDISPLACED FRACTURE IN MY
WRIST.
IT WAS SMALL, BUT STILL.
A NONDISPLACED CHIP.
I SHIPPED THE BONE, BUT IT DID
NOT LEAVE THE SERVICE, RIGHT?
IT HAD SHOWN THAT THE BONE HAD
GROWN OVER IT SO IT HEALED, BUT
IT WAS STILL PAIN.
I KEPT GETTING IT HIT OR
FALLING ON IT. I GUESS I PLAYED
WITH LIKE, SOMEWHAT OF A
FRACTURE FOR TWO MONTHS.
THEN, IN THE PLAYOFFS, THERE
WAS A PLAY AGAINST MILWAUKEE IN
GAME THREE.
I DUNKED IT.
THEY WERE CHASING ME DOWN AND
FOUND ME AND I FELL INTO, INTO
THE CROWD.
THAT WAS THE MOST PAINFUL IT
HAS BEEN SINCE THAT DAY THAT I
HURT IT.
I ENDED UP GETTING A CORTISONE
SHOT IN MY WRIST THAT NIGHT AND
YOU COULD SEE IT.
>> IT IS MUCH LIGHTER.
>> I'VE LOST COLOR IN MY HAND
BECAUSE IT KILLS THE FAT CELLS
AND THERERE'S NOA LOT OF FAT IN
MY HAND.
I LOST COLOR RIGHT THERE.
AFTER EACH GAME, I WOULD HAVE
TO WEAR A BRACE, TO SHOOT
AROUND, AND I WOULD TAKE IT OFF
BEFORE THE CAMERA SAW ME AND,
YOU KNOW,  PREGAME NAP, PUT IT
BACK ON JUST TO MAKE SURE POINT
>> SO, NO ONE KNEW YOU WERE
DEALING WITH THIS INJURY
BESIDES INTERNALLY.
>> BESIDES